next the brothers for Brazil we've been
following the case of two brothers
linked to a huge corruption scandal in
Brazil who have been buying up American
Meatpacking companies which it now turns
out have received some 100 million
dollars in US taxpayer money subsidies
meant for American farmers and ranchers
now members of Congress want to know
what's going on
from its highly produced corporate
promotional videos the JPS company
appears to be a great success built on
hard work and a commitment to corporate
responsibility started decades ago by a
small-time butcher in Brazil it has now
grown into a multi-billion dollar
worldwide beef poultry and pork producer
the largest in the world saying it
provides the world with quality food and
it has now bought up some of America's
best-known brands but what the company's
videos don't mention is the
scandal-plagued background big news in
Brazil of the two brothers who run the
company
jose lee and wesley batista sons of the
founder connected to a massive bribery
scheme in brazil that allegedly helped
them get the money to buy up the
american company
brazilian TV showing hidden camera
footage of the brothers supposedly
making backroom deals jbs is currently
under investigation by the Department of
Justice for potential violations of the
Foreign Corrupt Practices Act this is
because the Batista brothers the leading
shareholders have admitted to criminal
acts numerous criminal acts consisting
of the bribery of thousands of Brazilian
government officials to obtain illicit
loans from Brazil's national bank the
ill-gotten loans were then used by jbs
to illegally enter and consolidate the
meatpacking industry in the United
States questions about the company came
in to a sharper focus when it was
revealed the company had received tens
of millions of dollars in US taxpayer
money that President Trump said was
meant to help American farmers hit hard
by the trade war with China so we will
ensure that our farmers get the relief
they need and very very quickly it's
good time to be a farmer we're going to
make sure that jbs has received little
over 100 million dollars in payments
that money I might add was supposed to
have been for struggling farmers
ranchers who have been hurt by the
administration's failed trade policies
in a statement to Brian Ross
investigates the company said it has
quote fully cooperated with all relevant
authorities
in a transparent manner regarding past
events unquote and it says it is an
important American employer providing
more than 60,000 jobs and partnering
with more than eleven thousand farmers
ranchers and poultry producers but its
critics say that doesn't change the
facts of its illicit behavior so you're
saying this is a corrupt company and
these are the fruits of a poison tree
really these are the fruits of a poison
tree that's exactly right right and no
one should be able to profit from
ill-gotten gain out in the United States
you may get away with that in Brazil or
in other countries but you should not
get away with that in the United States
farmers and ranchers are being harmed
consumers are being deceived and it's
all been brought about because of the
illegal activity that was conducted in
Brazil joining us now for more on this
is Angela Huffman she's the executive
director of a group that represents
250,000 individual farmers and ranchers
called the Organization for competitive
markets and Angela thanks for being with
us tonight tell me is the upset about
that you have about this situation
because the brothers have this
background with corruption in Brazil or
because corporations are getting all
this money well the USDA has promoted
this program to Paris as a bailout for
America's farmers yet a Brazilian
corporation and of those funds it's not
fair to our taxpayers nor our farmers
but the fact is all corporations are
eligible for this money then the company
told us they have to sort of get the
money to be part of the program to
provide food and be part of the market
here that's right but the fact is jbs is
a criminal organization with a corporate
facade and this isn't the food system
that American taxpayers want yet we're
being forced to subsidize it in the name
of farmer bailouts there are also
questions that are being raised in
Congress about the safety record of this
company that's right in 2017 jbs was
involved in bribing brazilian meat
inspectors allowing them to sell an
export rotten meat
around the world including here in the
US and how has it been they've been able
to buy up so many meatpacking big names
we know here mm-hmm well through these
taxpayer bailouts jbs has profited on
the chair trade war with China they
announced back in August that they were
at their best point in the company's
history for global expansion and they're
just gobbling up Meatpacking companies
all around the world so the trade war
the China has helped them because they
continue to make more profits and
they're getting the subsidies as well
that's right yeah
while Chinese ports were shut down to
u.s. products as a result of the trade
war jbs started shipping and products
from its Brazilian facilities and in the
meantime the u.s. funneled a hundred
million dollars into jbs in the name of
US farmer bits the company told us they
think they're being unfairly targeted by
a lobbying campaign connected to a
financial deal that really has nothing
to do with this issue is that something
you know about that's not something we
know about we represent farmers and
ranchers who are really upset about the
results of this program and how do the
farmers around us what do they say to
you about this program and how it works
well they're they're struggling um you
know jbs admitted back in 2018 to
cheating America's farmers and ranchers
by paying them less than the real value
for their cattle at three separate beef
processing plants we've gotten a lot of
calls about that people are really upset
we should be investigating jbs finding
jbs not giving them taxpayer bailouts
and it appears there are some
investigations now underway according to
the congresswoman there are US
Department of Justice and the Securities
Exchange Commission are investigating
jbs were disappointed in the USDA and
Secretary Purdue just last week
Purdue let congresswoman DeLauro know
that he was declining to investigate
eight and not putting the bailout money
on hold in the meantime just last week
the US Government Accountability Office
announced its opening a review of the of
the bailout as well so we are making
progress but disappointed in USDA Angela
Huffman thank you so much for joining us
tonight thanks for having me Brian up
next our shoutout the reporter taking on
local officials who he says have been
purging thousands of people from the
voter rolls when we come back